the line in front of the Community
Kitchen gets longer every day poverty is
growing in London
[Music]
it's a situation that keeps Taz Khan
busy he knows that without him and his
privately run Food Bank many londoners
would go hungry let's go in
people that are in work actively both
husband and wife they are coming to
access our services and these are people
we would normally associate we've got
pensions that are coming so we've got an
increasing number of people that
normally wouldn't come to places like
this
every week Taz Khan provides food for 15
000 londoners
the Community Kitchen volunteers give
out 600 kilos of food per week at four
distribution sites in North London
they're busier than ever
Dana Russon is a single parent
she works half days in a department
store
almost every week she comes here to get
food for herself her two young sons and
her mother
it will be very difficult especially in
our days with the inflation and the
prices of growing out go up so much no
very difficult very different I didn't
know how could manage
Parikh Cuba also comes here almost every
week and loads up anything that's left
over he shares it with others
I don't need all of that
I just go around and give it to other
people who can't make it who can't come
here so most of it I'll give away Taz
Khan works with supermarkets and
suppliers they donate food that can no
longer be sold it's distributed quickly
part of his commitment to zero waste
zero hunger we thank the people that
come and use our service because they're
doing as a service if they don't take
the food that we offer up it's going to
end up in landfill and it's going to
damage the environment the gap between
rich and poor is particularly wide in
the UK compared to other affluent
countries
now Rising inflation and high energy
costs are driving more and more people
into poverty
especially families with children
the town of Hartley pool in northern
England is no exception
Daniel Burnside lives here with his
children
the self-employed painter wants to make
sure Coben and Esme always have enough
to eat
but that's easier said than done
turning on the heat is a luxury these
days
and it's been off for a couple of days
I've just had to just bear grim and wait
for the next paid payday or the next bit
of cash I can find to to put it on
same with electric I'll turn the lights
off on a night if I'm not on the house
it's in darkness
with inflation at over 10 percent Daniel
Burnside has to scrimp and save wherever
he can
sometimes he has to go without a hot
meal
just choices we have to make no
choices things that get sacrificed
you know my kids will have Beggars and
chips I might have a little bit you know
it's just rationing a lot
back in London Taz Khan has also opened
a cafe that serves inexpensive hot meals
it's run by volunteers
Rose and Simona come just about every
day both have mental health problems the
meal that they share together here is
often the only time they leave the house
it's Ultra special is a safe environment
so all the staff are so friendly and if
you had a bad day you would always find
someone's face and they come and support
you if you're eating out in another
place you can't afford it you can't
afford to do that so here it's
affordable and it's you've got
everything and you stay as long as you
want to stay
Taz Khan has invited London's mayor to
gain support for his next venture
training people who are out of work so
they can find jobs in the food and
restaurant industry
the mayor has promised to back the
project
I think Taz is inspirational our
building Community Food Bank are
literally making a massive difference
sometimes between life and death to
vulnerable families across our city and
it's a source of embarrassment to me
that one of the richest countries in the
world one of the richest cities in the
world needs facilities uh like this but
the reality is we do it food insecurity
is on the rise across the country
this is our social Market one in four
children every single day in the UK is
missing a meal so that's one in four
children that are missing a meal every
single day that's just where we are at
right now and what the future looks like
I don't know
[Music]
never been content to wait for others to
take action
not even the government
and this winter he's determined to help
as many people as possible
foreign